de este agua este la ira por la división
del gobierno y el estancamiento político
de libia ha llegado a un punto álgido
cuando los manifestantes irrumpieron en
el edificio del parlamento en la ciudad
oriental de tobruk
mientras que en trípoli en el western
del país los manifestantes
protagonizaron la mayor protesta vista
en años por nosotros los jóvenes hemos
salido hoy para exigir el fin del
período de transición queremos
elecciones este es el derecho del pueblo
libio y el derecho de los jóvenes las
calles son la base de la legislación
basta de transiciones queremos
elecciones legislativas y presidenciales
si dios quiere de la misma manera que
contra los políticos y la élite
gobernante los manifestantes expresaron
su enfado por los cortes crónicos de
energía y la falta de electricidad estos
disturbios se producen justo después de
que las fuerzas gobernantes de libia no
llegarán a un acuerdo sobre un marco
constitucional para las elecciones
nacionales en las conversaciones
mediadas por la onu en ginebra rica en
petróleo libia tiene dos gobiernos
rivales que se disputan el poder un
parlamento en tobruk dirigido por el
exministro del interior
jaja ha fiado al comandante militar
general jalifa hafter y el gobierno de
unidad con sede en trípoli y reconocido
formalmente por la onu y dirigido por
abdul hamid de bbva pero en ninguno de
los dos gobiernos está dispuesto a ceder
el poder el país está sumido en una
fuerte agitación social desde 2011
cuando tras cuatro décadas en el poder
el coronel muamar gadafi fue derrocado y
asesinado tras meses de revueltas